well I've talked about this film a ton
of times now I'm gonna talk about again
return to odds this is starting to get a
cult following as that film it scared
the shit out of you as a little kid but
we all really liked then yeah that's
kind of my memory too I don't remember
being so scared that I was crying at
this film or anything but yeah I do
remember being pretty damn creepy and
unsettling but it was okay because of
Jimmy Beck in was such a nice main
character and such nice side characters
and a lot of creativity and yeah you
know what I really like this flick even
if it does have a lot of dark creepy
elements speaking of which let's look at
the story dorothy having returned from
Oz talks all about the world she's been
to - auntie Anne but of course everybody
doesn't believe her at first they think
it's childish play but she just keeps
talking about and they're getting more
and more concerned and then she starts
to fall into a deep depression so
they're gonna take her to a doctor to
try this new method that apparently is
gonna fix her up right away it's called
shock therapy oh yeah I can see a lot of
good things coming from this but one of
the nurses or was it patients it was
never quite sure saves Dorothy and sends
her out in the middle of the storm
actually might have been safer just to
leave her there but when she wakes up
she's back in the Land of Oz but the
Scarecrow is no longer in charge like
when she left instead it's taken over by
this evil queen with a million heads and
the Nome King who soon will have control
of all of Oz and Dorothy is the key
along the way she comes across some
interesting characters like a robot
named tick-tock
another scarecrow a creation called Jack
Pumpkinhead a talking chicken and even a
flying couch yeah how's that for an
out-there cast of characters and that's
the word to describe this movie out
there there are some strange creepy
creations in this like the wheelers oh
my god these things first pop up they'll
scare any kid a lot of the shots and
imagery in this film a lot of critics
complain are too scary and yeah okay I'm
not gonna act like I don't see where
they're coming from but in my opinion it
never goes too far
it never goes bloody it never goes too
gritty it never goes sexual it never
goes into a thing that's epic
bad it's just creepy but yeah a lot of
kids can't handle creepy stuff have your
kids are frightened by this
yeah I'll understand I'm not
recommending it for everybody but let's
be honest there's a lot of kids out
there that like to be afraid I was one
of them I know plenty of people that
were too and the fact that this film
does have such a following from people
that love it not because it's so bad
it's good but because it's so good it's
good there is a charm to these
characters and there is a kindness and
Dorothy is very likeable and tick tock
is a great character and Jack it's a
like a much I like these characters and
I like this world even if it is kind of
in ruins the whole movie has sort of a
surreal dreamlike quality that both
ranges from really Pleasant nice dreams
into horrific nightmares but I think
there's a lot of kids and adults they
can relate to that if it was nothing but
hardships all the way through or didn't
have a good nice main character then it
probably wasn't too worked but there are
some decent moments and there was a nice
creative times and there is a lot of
kindness from our main cast and like I
said the creativity is wonderful there's
a lot of stop motion in this film and it
looks really great it actually reminds
me a lot of the Harryhausen days it just
looks really good and the rest of the
facts are damn impressive - there's so
many puppets or so many giant sets it's
just a great looking film I think for me
when I was a kid I respected films like
this because I felt like they were
giving me a chance to feel a little
older they were trying to scare me they
were trying to make me a little tougher
and I didn't mind that I wanted
something that was gonna challenge me a
bit and for kids is something that's
scary but still engaging is kind of
challenging how can we like something
that we assume is bad for us and gonna
scare us but yet we keep watching it I
did a whole editorial about this and you
own your more about it go watch that but
that's not why I'm here
I'm here to review this movie and in the
end I think it's a damn good movie I
think it's charming it has a lot of
heart and yes it has a whole lot of
scares but their creative scares and
they're fun scares and in my opinion
they never go too far is it like the
last cinematic Wizard of Oz no it's
something entirely different as based
more on the books which could get really
can really grip but the reason they work
back then is because there was this
charm tool man there's a charm to this
movie too
so I can't help but really enjoy it if
you're curious for yourself check it out
and get ready to have your childhood but
Jesus is scared out